Okay, so to share videos and photos, I
will click on the Discussion thread with a star.
Now, the star means that I created this thread
for you to submit your responses. Once the discussion
forum has opened, you can simply scroll down
and add a YouTube link right here to the
discussions. You will notice that there is a YouTube
video that is embedded right within the discussion forum.
There. Now let's talk about how to upload a
photo. To do that, I will click on this
tiny photo icon, and then simply upload a photo
from my computer. That's the one I want to upload.
And you will notice that much like the YouTube
video, the photo is also uploaded right here within the
discussion forums. Let me hit Submit, and done. So
here I am, back to the mini project, which is
for you to teach the program that we have
written together, to a friend or a colleague. We also
want you to use your smartphone to record a video
of your conversation. And then share that YouTube video with
us on the discussion forum. Oh, by the way, if you are
an unable to record a video, we would love to see some
photos or some text describing your conversation with your friend. After you've
submitted your responses on the forum, make sure you check this box.